hello everyone today I want to talk to
you about gene set enrichment analysis
now gene set enrichment analysis is a
way to analyze your express genes as
they are enriched in a specific gene set
so for example you have a data set from
NCBI you want to download the raw fast Q
files and then you can use the T bio
info platform to process those raw files
into a table of expression now here's
the table here's the platform the T
mindful platform and over here under RNA
seek you would be able to create a
pipeline that will connect multiple
analysis steps together so that you can
go from start to then mapping for
example on transcripts to then creating
an expression table and then finally
differential expression analysis for
example this is a pipeline that you
would create so you go from start to
bowtie - t - RS m and then de-sect - now
an interesting thing that you can do
with the table that shows you the fold
change between two groups and the
p-value you can use this method called
gauge which stands for generally
applicable gene set enrichment for
pathway analysis how do we do that so
the first thing that you need to do
here's our table of differentially
expressed genes from deseg - the output
looks like this you have gene IDs so
these are ENS G so there are ensembl IDs
and then you have a number of columns
that show you how they are
differentially expressed for example you
can use the adjusted p-value analog to
fold change to identify statistically
significant expression differences
between groups and measure their fold
change however gage cannot use these
ensemble eggies it typically uses on
or jeans simple IDs so a way you can
translate those is through annotation
you can input the deseg to output table
that we were just looking at upload it
and then select annotation to convert it
to table that will look like this so
this is important to remember that you
will have the transcript lady in
Ensemble and then right here you would
use the gene symbol and so to simplify
this you can just take this column move
it right here and then delete the rest
because the rest is not going to be
relevant for the gene set in which my
analysis so you will have transcript
gene symbol base main log twofold change
and those are essentially the columns
that you need
how would you perform the gene set
enrichment analysis this is the final
file this is the final pipeline and I
will show you in a second what's inside
here but let's for a second create this
pipeline from scratch to demonstrate to
you how this works so let's add files
this is the output that I was just
showing you that has the ID and the gene
symbol so let's choose this file wait
until it uploads continue click on start
once we start we click on OK and then
now let's select human gauge now the
header we we do have a header right so
we have transcript gene symbol this is
the first row that's called the header
so we are going to say yes where do we
have the gene 80s now this is not the
not the transcript ID this is the gin
gene symbol so that's in column number
two and then here what we need is the
column with gene differential expression
so this is log full change of p-value so
you can see log full change that is one
two three four column
four so that's right here and the rest
you can keep the same the only thing is
you can choose the different gene sets
that we have already on the platform so
in this case we want to get pathway
analysis so we'll use KEGG pathways the
empty our threshold is another important
feature here that the that will enable
the script to generate visual images of
pathways from CAG and the in which genes
so the higher the threshold the more you
will get in terms of your the number of
pathway images okay so you can for
example change it to 0.5 now I can click
on OK
and and then let's save this
remember as you can see it says human
gauge the reason it says human gauge is
because gage only works with human files
now let's take a look at the output and
go under my pipelines and I just ran
this pipeline and now I can take a look
at what's inside so I see the zip file
let's download it so here's a zip file
and let's see what's inside so first of
all what I can see is a number of
pathway images where I have highly
expressed genes it's red and low
expressed genes as green so you can see
that there are green ones and red ones
for each one of these pathways now I
have a bunch of them but also I have
this table right here that I can use so
inside again we have a list of those
same pathway names and they actually
tell us what they are responsible for so
you see the map K signaling pathway and
that is 0 for 0 of 10 they can go 0 for
0 10 right here sorry 0 for 0 10 right
here and this is the map K pathway so
you can see the gene names and you can
see whether the expression was high red
or low green and you can see that it's
fairly enriched so now you have a list
of all of these and you have a table
that shows you their p-value and just a
p-value and set size now this is going
to be used for your cutoff you remember
our cutoff was 0.01 or 0 we increased it
so this is going to be your cutoff for
what we have so a total and goes from 0
to
so let's see the last one is zero three
zero forty so you're three zero forty
it's not here
see so what's the last one that we have
let's go to 0.01 0.05 so zero zero five
three two zero zero five three two right
there
and the next one is going to be zero
zero three ten so zero zero three ten
and you don't see it anymore so that's
because we set our cutoff at zero point
five okay so according to this column
this is Q value which is an adjusted p
value which is essentially FDR so that
was our threshold and so changing this
threshold doesn't change this table it
just changes how many images you will
get now the same thing is important to
remember for when you run gauge but
without not on KEGG pathways so
obviously if you don't have the KEGG
pathways you're not gonna be having
these images in your results and now how
is this useful well this is very useful
actually in the following way
you can have an extra gene over a table
of expression and then use that table of
expression to identify differences in
gene expression between two groups and
then you can translate this information
into biological insight by looking at
enrichment of pathways I hope that this
was informative you can go ahead and try
it out on different types of gene sets
remember this is only going to work for
human genes and before you run human
gauge you have to transform the table
and to an annotated table so in other
words use the annotation button under
utilities you have this annotation
button
to transform the de-sect to table into a
table with gene symbols or entrees a
tease